[Musique]
à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes ce
mercredi 8 mars le département de La
Réunion a souhaité rendre hommage à ses
dames c'est ainsi que son président
Cyril Melchior a démarré sa matinée dans
les hauts de Saint-Paul en allant à la
rencontre de l'association auront
d'athon sur ce terrain de 5000 mètres
carrés cette femme et trois hommes en
contrepèques pour parcours emploi
compétences cultive patate maniocte ou
encore plante médicinales aujourd'hui
monsieur le Président et son équipe
s'est déplacée pour voir un peu notre
projet l'association féminin notre
potager fait 5000 m², et franchement
c'est un beau projet pour pour des
femmes l'agriculture on dit entre
guillemets c'est fait pour les hommes
mais au moins 3 jours d'hui que nous les
femmes on peut y arriver aussi au cours
de la visite du potager le président du
département n'a pas manqué de saluer
l'initiative portée par l'association
on voit beaucoup d'exploitantes
agricoles des personnes qui se sont
engagées et ici dans les hauts de
Saint-Paul et bien une association
exempleaire offre du travail aux femmes
dans le domaine agricole travail
formation
pour l'activité économique ce sont là
les maîtres mots qui guident cette
action et donc c'est pour ça que je
salue le travail de toutes les femmes
qui s'engagent dans l'économie de l'île
en particulier dans le développement
agricole de l'île je salue le travail
des femmes qui sont des présidents
d'associations comme ici avec Madame
cerveau je salue le travail des femmes
qui s'engagent dans le développement de
l'île dans tous les domaines transports
publics bâtiment agriculture commerce
aide à la personne dans tous les
domaines on voit le rôle des femmes et
ce et essentiel donc bravo azote et on
continue bien évidemment parce que notre
société a besoin d'être encore plus
exemplaire en matière d'égalité
homme-femme la matinée c'est poursuivie
à l'antenne départementale de Savannah
toujours sur le thème de l'insertion
professionnelle des femmes ici jeune et
seniors ont présenté le résultat
d'ateliers intergénérationnel piloté par
les agents des directions de la jeunesse
et de l'insertion dans le cadre de la
Journée des droits de la femme avec des
jeunes qu'on accompagne donc un
accompagnement socio professionnel et
des signaux que nous accompagnons dans
le cas des ateliers numériques
on a mis en place des atelier
d'intégrationnel où il y a eu des
jugeons des jeunes et les seniors pour
préparer cette journée donc aujourd'hui
c'était vraiment maître à l'honneur donc
je venais de la femme des droits de la
femme donc chaque jeune chaque site de
recherche participant dans le cas des
ateliers on peut parler des petits cœurs
donc ça pour l'accoucher et c'était
aussi l'occasion de faire des groupes de
parole pour parler des conditions de la
femme de la représentation de la femme
aujourd'hui à la Réunion et dans le
monde pour conclure cette matinée
conjuguée au féminin Cyril Melchior a
organisé un déjeuner débat avec les
conseillères des départementales et les
conseillères départementales des jeunes
autour de l'engagement des femmes dans
le monde politique local après une
rétrospective sur la place et le droit
des femmes à la Réunion chacune des
invités a pu s'exprimer partager sa
vision son parcours et ses expériences
un moment très inspirant notamment pour
les jeunes conseillères départementales
de l'engagement des femmes dans la
politique et c'est un sujet qui a
beaucoup résolu en moi parce que bah
personnellement
et la politique c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse vraiment j'ai envie d'aider
les gens depuis mon plus jeune âge j'ai
de m'investir dans la République alors
en tant de témoignages de femmes qui
sont investis qui sont respectées dans
leur milieu
je pense que ça va vraiment beaucoup
touché ça va surtout inspirer et en tant
que femme j'ai envie de devenir comme
elle plus tard et d'inspirer de votre
jeune femme à mon tour à s'intéresser à
la politique une journée ponctuée par
des moments de convivialité mais surtout
d'échanges sur la condition des femmes
réunionnaises
[Musique]